so today we're going to be asking people
in walmart who they think weighs more do
a full thing do a full spin let us know
in the comments who you think weighs
[Music]
yeah but it's not bad so
which i want you to guess both of our
weights like that's my weight and guess
her way
go stand next to her
see what an inch taller
um five eleven and a half yeah
i'm five ten whatever it is i weigh the
same okay
i think it's just that
the inch
and the build
makes it look different but whatever it
is it's the same
you can guess we won't be yeah we won't
get offended 511 yeah and i'm
let's be right right on oh you're
getting close
together
yeah like i'd say within like what
maybe five yeah ten pounds okay
for her
or do you think we're both 200. she's
not she's far from me i'm 190. she's
doing something
to say one night but i was looking for a
gift card for playing because the first
person i played which one do you want i
have one starbucks subway tacos
i like starbucks okay
thank you
thank you
so you have to guess how much i weigh
and how much she weighs and if you get
close you're going to get five
we won't get it yeah we won't be
offended yeah
we've heard high and low
and yeah much do you think she weights
[Laughter]
no
i'm one i'm she's wearing 75 i'm 190.
yeah
thanks for playing so you don't have to
answer the question how much do you
think i weigh and how much you can she
weighs and if you're close you want to
get five
we won't be offended you don't have to
that was terrible no it wasn't you
actually went through it
is that your final answer no it's not it
okay yeah okay
so i think you're like 165 years
you're like one one
i'm trying to get a final answer for her
is 165.
i'm trying to help you out here
or like one no like once okay 170 170
like 170.
okay 71.75 okay okay i think you're like
well i still think one 160 160. oh my
god he thinks he weighed less than me
no we've gotten this a lot no i'm
actually 190. she's 175. but you really
got one though so much gift card would
you like panetta taco bell subway
where's starbucks
for sure
okay so
how much do you think i weigh and how
much do you think she weighs if we won't
be offended
well
personally
she looks like she's probably about
140.
okay what do you think for her
like this beautiful girl
i figured probably
150
155 no more than 160. okay yeah i'm 190.
she's 175.
thank you guys thank you you've earned
high and low numbers okay just ask it
again
so how much
how much do you think we weigh if you
get it within
[Music]
[Music]
you got 140 she's 155 is that your final
answer
no
you can give you input if you want that
she's taller
she's tall so i'm just for height she's
thank you
what do you think
and just you know she's 5 10 i'm 5 11.
both average women too so i'm gonna have
to give you all about above average
numbers i'm gonna say you guys are
between one
seventy one eighty five one seven so you
think she's 170
or 185 what's what's your number that
you guessed i'm gonna go 175 for both of
us yes
okay
so i'm
so what do you oh yeah
what do you want to get
awesome
[Music]
we will not be offended at all by the
answer but we're asking people how much
do you think we win
we won't be defended as we yeah how much
do you think we went just for reference
i'm 5 11 and a half
she's five times
190
190
[Music]
yeah no one's 90 girls
what's your favorite and you
six see things six
um
i'm gonna say like a good
one like
something 190 something what's your
final 190 or 1.95
196 196 okay what do you think for her
um like
she's like in like the 70s
60s 170 is that your answer 170 yeah
175.
what 175. i'll say 173. okay and then
what what did you say i think
the same issues
you know you guys are the closest today
i'm 190. she's 175. thank you
thank you